Speaker 1: All right. Let's continue
our tour of the insanity. That was the
Turning Point USA student event in Tampa, Florida.
They really get the students fired up. This is a
full on indoctrination type event. This is
the type of thing you would imagine is taking
place done by the government of North Korea, for
example. And the we've actually seen and talked
about such events in North Korea. One of the we've
already looked at what Donald Trump said. One of
the other speakers was donald trump jr. Now
we've seen a lot of video of donald trump jr.
I have never seen him this wired. And of
course, the speculation is that he is on
some kind of upper. There are different
opinions as to what upper that is.
I will sort of stop my analysis there, but making
very, very little sense, really hopped up, sped up
and this video is not sped up. Importantly.
Speaker 4: Like I've never seen it like she
can do like a half an hour and
like there's like three words.
No, it's it's like I don't know whether
to be, like, upset or impressed, you know,
like the crazy crap the Hillary was saying last
week. She's like, Yeah, that's perfect. Here.
Carmelo is your speech writer. Like Carmela.
Like, that's next. And the only thing scarier
again than perhaps Joe Biden would be come up.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So this is his anti kamala rant.
Don Jr then moving on to claiming COVID
variants are invented, conspiracy theories
and all sorts of other stuff that should should
get you put in a loony bin, quite frankly. And
I know that that's not a politically correct
term. It should make us question one's sanity,
but the crowd loves it. The crowd cheers.
This is a crowd where this stuff is rewarded.
Speaker 4: Remember, folks, the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the truth.
It used to be about six months, right? Was there
anything? All the things we've been talking about.
Has there been one that we were
wrong about in the end? Meaning
we were told we were wrong. We were
canceled. If you were a doctor and
you questioned Clown Fauci, you know, you
were thrown out of the medical profession.
Any one of those things. Turns out they were
right. Huh? It doesn't matter. We got what we
wanted. Let's move on. The difference is,
now it's like 6 minutes, right? Between
what your labeled conspiracy theory turns out
to be the truth. They can't hide anymore because
it's compounding so badly. It just doesn't
stop. And we're going to see this more, right?
We're either going to have a midterm variance,
obviously. Right. Right. So they can implement
whatever they need to do fraudulent voting and
whatever it may be. Or you're you're seeing.
You guys are seeing it. You know it's
coming. The monkey pox pandemic, folks.
Speaker 1: This is another one which
again, they they're they're taking
both sides of the monkeypox stuff where
on the one hand, they're starting to say
COVID clearly was some kind of concocted psyop,
because now we've got monkey pox. And the nobody's
saying we got to shut down because of monkey pox.
That proves something about COVID was fake. It's
like, well, though covid's a respiratory
virus, it spreads extraordinarily easily.
Monkeypox is spreading through physical
contact, sexual contact, skin to skin.
So the transmission is completely different.
So why would the reaction be the same?
But at the same time, they're starting to say
monkey pox is being set up to do the same thing
that they did with they did with COVID. So they'll
they'll have it both ways on all of these things.
One other kind of funny moment was now Don Jr
is rewriting history about when Trump had to be
helped down that ramp by by a general.
Speaker 4: Remember when Trump
walked down a ramp and it was like raining and
slippery, so he held onto the banister and it
was like he's in the later stages of dementia
and Alzheimer's combined. He is literally about
to drop dead. Oh, my God. Our 25th Amendment.
Speaker 1: Now, it was actually not raining that
day. It was sunny. And I went back just because
I was like my misremembering the day that Trump
walked down the ramp. It was a beautiful sunny
day at the time that Donald Trump walked down
with his hand held by the general. Doesn't change
anything one way or the other. Not a big deal,
but they're just straight up rewriting history
at this point and the crowd loves it. Now,
last thing, Donald Trump also has evidence
that he is being suppressed and that the right
is being suppressed, which is his posts
don't get as many likes as they used to.
Speaker 4: Have you ever noticed it
only goes one way? Yeah. Like, you know,
I'm getting like 10,000 likes a post from
like 300,000 like couple of months ago because
they don't like me right now. Right. You're
effective. They're going to suppress you.
We are working that much harder now.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that's the new proof
that of course, there is some subterfuge at play.
Don Jr is getting fewer likes, so the crowd loves
it. Don Jr is hopped up as I've ever seen him and
the hits just came. Coming next is Lauren Boebert